[Music]
duping items has been discovered as a
new bug in blood-borne and here's a
quick guide on how to do it of course do
this at your own risk
first and foremost you will need to have
two characters so if you don't already
have a second one make sure to make an
alternate character it doesn't matter
what kind of character you make after
getting your weapon to kill off the wolf
proceed until you get to the next
Lantern which is right up the ladder
return now to the hunters dream next go
back to your main character or the
character you want to dupe items on and
clear out everything from the storage
you can either sell the items or just
discard them but everything needs to be
cleared out of the storage once you've
done this switch back to your alternate
character now when you're back on your
secondary character go ahead and
purchase one pebble now take that pebble
and put it in your storage the pebble
should be the only thing that's in your
storage after doing that switch back to
your primary character duping items only
works on items that are stackable so
weapons and gems will not work however
items like blood shards twin blood
shards madmen stones and items you
consume to receive echoes will work
here's what you need to do now that your
storage is empty put one of the items
you want into the storage make sure
you're only putting a quantity of one in
here though for example we'll put a
blood shard in next proceed in the
messenger store and buy pebbles the best
way to do this assuming you want a huge
quantity of a duked item is to have 20
pebbles in your inventory because the
extra pebbles that are purchased will
then show up as dupe items after
purchasing the pebbles head back to the
storage voila
you now have dupe that consumable item X
number of times based on how many
pebbles you ended up putting into the
storage if you want to do something else
take out all of the items to ensure the
storage is empty again and put a
quantity of one of the item you want to
do and rinse and repeat if you ever get
stuck where it doesn't appear to be
duping make sure to clear the storage
out on the primary character then log on
to your second character take the pebble
out of the storage and reinsert it for
some reason if there's ever more than
just one item in the storage on the
primary character
won't dupe what you want again caution
in the wind as using the strategy but
this is how you do items in blood-borne
currently
[Music]
you